given the graph of y equals f of X
pictured below determine the equations
of all vertical asymptotes so let's see
what's going on here so it looks like
interesting things are happening at x
equals negative 4 and x equals 2 at x
equals negative 4 as we approach it from
the left the value of the function just
becomes unbounded right over here it
looks like as we approach x equals
negative 4 from the left the value of
our function goes to infinity likewise
as we approach x equals negative 4 from
the right it looks like our route the
value of our function goes to infinity
so I'd say that we definitely have a
vertical asymptote at x equals negative
4 now let's look at x equals 2
as we approach x equals 2 from the left
now for the value of our function once
again approaches infinity or it becomes
unbounded now from the right we have an
interesting thing if we if we look at
the limit from the right right over here
it looks like we're approaching a finite
value as we approach x equals 2 from the
right it looks like we're approaching f
of X is equal to negative 4 but just
having a one-sided limit that is
unbounded is enough to think about this
as a vertical asymptote the function is
not defined right over here and as we
approach it from just one side we are
becoming unbounded but it looks like
we're approaching infinity or negative
infinity so that by itself this
unbounded left-hand limit or left-side
limit by itself is enough to consider x
equals 2 a vertical asymptote so we
could say that there's a vertical
asymptote at x equals negative 4 and x
equals 2